et has your Royal roundup st. Patrick's
Day edition is pretty impressive the
Royal started their busy Friday at
London's annual st. Patty's Day parade
naturally Kate Middleton greeted a few
friends along the route to parade mascot
a giant Irish Wolfhound dressed in red
and an adorable seven year old
presenting the Duchess of Cambridge with
flowers of course Kate looked the part
wearing an emerald green Catherine
Walker coat and matching heels and hat
while Prince William sported a clean-cut
uniform with a hint of green in his hat
and the couple also celebrated the
holiday with a royal toast
check out Kate and William with a pint
of Guinness in hand and even better
Kate downing her own drink then the Duke
and Duchess jetted off to Paris for a
two-day tour upon their arrival the
couple met with the French president at
his residence
the Alesi palace later Kate and William
attended an over-the-top gala where Kay
pulled out all the stops with her
ensembles the Duchess wore a sleeveless
black Alexander McQueen gown paired with
a gorgeous drop down necklace then she
made a quick change into this stunning
silver gown for dinner at the British
Embassy while once again Kate Wow's us
with her incredible style
you